madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal le temps se prononce pour la
mise en place d'un blocus naval dans
l'adriatique pour empêcher
l'approvisionnement en pétrole de la
yougoslavie
jacques chirac émet des réserves quant à
l'application de ce blocus moscou
déclare ne pas vouloir respecter cet
embargo
en france la solidarité de la communauté
serbe à destination des victimes des
bombardements yougoslavie des livres et
des médicaments devraient parvenir aux
populations les cadres du rpr réunis à
paris à l'unisson autour de nicolas
sarkozy qui prêche pour le rassemblement
et l'unité derrière jacques chirac
le nouveau spectacle de la chorégraphe
pina bausch à paris cette fois ci
inspiré de son voyage à lisbonne
la chaleur et la sensualité sur la scène
du théâtre de la ville
je vous propose d'ouvrir ce journal avec
cette décision prise hier par le temps
d'imposer l'embargo sur les ventes de
pétrole à destination de la yougoslavie
et du monténégro l'application de ce
dispositif pourrait passer par un blocus
naval et c'est là que divergent les
positions de l'alliance avec cette
question comment mettre en oeuvre y
compris par les armes un blocus maritime
en mer adriatique jacques chirac
émettent de sérieuses réserves
bernard lebrun contrôler les navires en
mer adriatique la flotte militaire des
nations de l'otan a longuement appris à
le faire durant la guerre en bosnie
entre juin 1993 et octobre 1996 ces
bâtiments interpellé quelque 74 milles
navires marchands dont 6000 auront fait
l'objet d'inspections à bord au total
1400 était dérouté après contrôle pour
cause d'embargo sur les armes et les
matières premières
c'est cette opération alors baptisée
sharqc ward car de vives que les chefs
d'état ont décidé de remettre en place
hier soir
premier objectif de cette mission tarir
l'approvisionnement des forces serbes en
pétrole en surveillant les 180 km de co
du monténégro seule façade maritime de
la république fédérale de yougoslavie
l'embargo fait l'unanimité en revanche
les règles d'un raisonnement voir
d'engagement militaire contre les
navires
refusant d'obtempérer provoque des
divergences entre les pays membres de
l'otan sur tout cela pour toutes sortes
de raisons je suis personnellement tout
à fait réserver et je n'ai pas grand cas
de le dire tu pas tout à fait le seul
non plus sans surprise la russie a
immédiatement condamné la décision de
l'otan sont atteints à moscou victor
tchernomirdine l'émissaire pour la
yougoslavie désigné par boris eltsine
c'est carrément mise en colère et
apprenant la nouvelle
le blocus est mauvais dit il les frappe
c est quand les gens meurent c'est
mauvais en voyage au caire le chef de la
diplomatie russe a été plus catégorique
encore et décision de l'otan sont
contraignantes seulement pour ses 19
membres
personne ne peut imposer de telles
sanctions sans l'accord de l'onu
en clair moscou ne respectera pas
l'embargo contre belgrade alors question
que se passera-t-il demain si un
pétrolier russe se présente devant les
côtes du monténégro pour le coup un vrai
risque d'extension du conflit peut
naître de ce blocus
dans l'immédiat les bâtiments de guerre
qui croise en adriatique qu'ils soient
britanniques français ou américains
n'ont toujours pas reçu de consignes sur
les procédures d'engagement
nous le disions l'interdiction de vente
du pétrole touche aussi bien la
yougoslavie que le monténégro et cette
situation qui fragilise un peu plus la
république monténégrin serait assorti
d'un blocus maritime précisément sur la
côte sud du pays une décision qui fait
l'effet d'une sanction pour cette
population qui a souvent pris ses
distances avec le pouvoir serbe sur
place nos envoyés spéciaux
benoît duquesne jean-françois renoux
officiellement ce sont les plus grandes
réserves pétrolières du pays
une série de cuves pour stocker les
produits raffinés nous sommes au port de
bach l'endroit est zone militaire et
filmé est interdite paradoxe quand on
arrive à la pompe la file d'attenté est
conséquente
c'est pourtant ici qu'arrivent la
majeure partie du pétrole consommé au
monténégro l'embargo est pour l'instant
théorique mais le rationnement lui
paraît réel mais personne n'en parle
devant la caméra on fait la queue ont
rempli des jerrycans
mais tout cela serait normal j'habite
loin d'ici dans un village où il n'ya
pas de pompe à essence c'est pour ça que
je remplis les bidons d'essence non non
non je n'ai pas peur de ça même si j'en
ai entendu parler
en discutant un peu plus on finit quand
même par nous dire que les camions quand
ils viennent ne livre que 2000 litres
d'essence dans les stations et que le
diesel est rationnée 20 litres à la fois
pas plus alors on stocke par précaution
mais sans l'avouer car embargo ou pas on
est solidaires ici face à l'otan et
voyez mon père avec les soixante dix ans
en pétrole alors moi je peux bien tenir
60 ans sans problème
on va tenir vous savez notre peuple très
fort malgré la pression lambard oli
frappe pour nous faire oublier qu'ils
sont une honte de la france et des pays
de l'europe mais tarde marinovich a lui
aussi pris ses précautions et s'il nous
reçoit chez lui s'il accepte de nous en
parler c'est surtout pour nous donner la
version officielle du gouvernement
imposé un embargo au monténégro serait
une catastrophe pour l'économie du pays
vous savez cette essence n'ira pas à
l'armée yougoslave
elle nous est destinée à nous qui en
avons besoin pour cultiver la terre il
ne faut pas nous imposer un embargo
le maire de bar ne dit pas autre chose
le gouvernement accepterait même des
contrôles
de l'onu pour bien s'assurer que
l'essence n'aille pas aux militaires le
gouvernement ne permettra pas que les
100 soit donné à l'armée
la distribution va être faite uniquement
selon les besoins des citoyens du
monténégro
vous savez ils ont suffisamment prouvé
lors des dernières élections le
rattachement à la communauté
internationale et l ouverture vers
l'euro membres pour les plus modérés des
monténégrins et bien sûr pour le pouvoir
cet embargo n'aurait pas s'il se réalise
que les conséquences économiques il
aurait bien sûr aussi des conséquences
politiques
ce serait sans doute un élément de plus
qui pourraient pousser les habitants de
cette petite république vers le grand
frère de serbie ce que justement le
gouvernement essaye d'éviter à
washington les 19 membres des pays de
l'otan se sont retrouvés ce matin après
le conseil de guerre qui ouvrait le
sommet du cinquantenaire de l'alliance
hier les débats ont repris autour d'une
action plus globale concernant la
stratégie de l'otan à venir
l'accord franco américain a fait état
d'une action conforme aux principes des
nations unies jacques chirac a affirmé
tout à l'heure que le temps doit être
sûr de son bon droit et cela exige le
respect des règles du droit
international et nous rejoignent en
direct de washington ne leur en boussier
aujourd'hui donc à l'ordre du jour les
missions de l'otan pour le nouveau
millénaire avec en fait une
réaffirmation du rôle des nations unies
pour les responsables de l'otan il
s'agissait aujourd'hui de définir un
nouveau concept stratégique qui
définissent le rôle de l'alliance pour
le 21e siècle
or depuis la fin de la guerre froide
évidemment le monde a changé à la
mission principale de l'alliance qui
était la défense de l'europe en tête en
cas d'attaqué d'autres missions ont été
ajoutées comme le maintien de la paix la
gestion de crise la lutte contre le
terrorisme contre les armes de
destruction massive ou contre la
prolifération nucléaire alors sur ses
nouvelles missions il ya eu un consensus
assez facile entre les 19 chefs d'état
c'est plutôt sur l'application les
discussions ont été très longues en
particulier entre français et américains
jacques chirac voulait que la
prééminence de l'onu sur l'otan soient
explicités et de manière tout à fait
tout à fait clair alors que les
américains qui ont toujours préféré
l'otan pour leurs opérations militaires
ne voulait pas se lier les mains avec un
texte trop contraignants en plein compte
qu il semble que ce soit la version
française et européenne qu'il est
emporté puisque le texte final
arles du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
qui a une responsabilité je cite
primordial dans le maintien de la paix
et laurent à ce qu'est ce que les
actions en cours au que ce nous font
partie de ce nouveau cadre écouté le
kosovo c'est un peu la pratique avant la
théorie une action militaire hors zone
géographique 2 du traité de l'atlantique
nord
un mandat pas très bien définie de
défini de l'onu pour les américains
c'est l'exemple de ce qui pourrait
arriver au siècle prochain pour les
planchers pour les français c'est pas du
tout ça pour eux il s'agit d'une
exception une exception qu'il ne
faudrait pas recommencer merci laurent
boussier à belgrade plus de 5000
personnes manifestaient cet après midi
autour des locaux de la télévision serbe
détruit hier par les missiles de l'otan
bouquet de fleurs et bougies déposées à
la mémoire des victimes selon les
autorités yougoslave
une dizaine de personnes ont été tuées
et 18 autres blessés alors que des
personnes encore emmuré dans le bâtiment
arrivera à communiquer par téléphone
portable avec les sauveteurs ce
bombardement a suscité la protestation
du gouvernement italien
et puis cet après midi le porte parole
de l'otan a indiqué lui que l'alliance
allait continuer à bombarder la
radio-télévision serbe
ces émetteurs instrument de propagande
au kosovo les serbes de christina soit
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont
manifesté leur opposition bombardement
de la télévision serbe voulant montrer
que la vie continue même sous les
frappes de l'alliance des parties
d'échecs ont été organisées dans la
ville à rome en italie plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de manifestants se
sont retrouvés pour défendre l'idée
d'une paix juste au kosovo sous une
pluie battante la mobilisation d'une
partie de la jeunesse italienne à la
salle francs
le ciel n'était pas de gauche à rome cet
après-midi pour cette manifestation un
terreau pn pour ce site un monde nouveau
une pluie diluvienne s'est abattue sur
le cortège pendant tout le trajet sans
décourager vraiment l'ardeur populaire
ils étaient des dizaines de milliers à
braver les intempéries
une heure après l'arrivée des premiers
piazza del popolo
ils étaient encore des milliers à un
kilomètre de là devant la trinité des
monts à l'origine
la manifestation était organisée contre
le racisme mais actualité oblige elle
est devenue un rassemblement pour la
paix paradoxalement organisée par un
parti au pouvoir en italie favorables à
l'intervention de l'otan de même que son
équivalent français
je pense qu'il n'y a aucun gouvernement
qui pète pour la guerre on peut avoir
des gouvernements comme le gouvernement
français ou italiens qui sont pour les
droits humaines et donc ils sont
aujourd'hui dans la situation de
soutenir une intervention militaire pour
la paix mais pour une paix juste pour
une paix qui permettra au cauchemar de
rentrer chez eux
du coup on ne savait plus très bien si
cette manifestation était pour ou contre
la guerre d'un côté ont distribué des
tee shirt cible comme à belgrade
de l'autre ont soutenu le gouvernement
on est là pour dire qu'ils sont des
assassins
la dirigeante et c'est parti à appuyer
sur les boutons avec la route ng sui
avec la politique de ces gouvernements
examen qui a fait c'est bien malgré lui
c'est ça le miracle italien faire une
seule manifestation à la fois pour et
contre
avec la pluie pour tous
avant d'en venir au sort des réfugiés
qui continuent de fuir le kosovo je vous
propose dessus cette histoire exemplaire
tout commence dans la banlieue de
bordeaux à ce nouveau vide depuis 26 ans
une famille que ce bar en regardant le
journal télévisé à riffa la mère croit
reconnaître dans une file de réfugiés en
macédoine
plusieurs de ses proches commencent
alors des recherches qui finiront par
aboutir près de tetovo david basique et
frédéric d'un chèque et en macédoine
parce qu'elle joue c'est bon emmanuel
bec depuis le début du conflit les loups
tic scrute les journaux télévisés dans
l' angoisse
un soir arrive pas aperçoit sa famille
du kosovo dans une file de réfugiés
c'est comme cela qu'est là dessus qu'ils
étaient vivants puis de 15 jours que
j'avais pas de nouvelles du tour
national je ne sais pas zarif à n'a
qu'une idée accueillir sa famille du
kosovo chez elle avec l'aide du maire
elle entre en contact avec une
représentante d'une association
humanitaire qui lui permet de retrouver
les siens
hébergé chez un paysan macédonien donc
ce qu'il faut mais par contre comme ils
peuvent pas bouger c'est leur envoyer un
véhicule jusqu'au moment où j'ai foi je
sais pas
parce qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de
circuler le maire harcèle le ministère
des affaires étrangères l'ambassade en
macédoine pour obtenir leur rapatriement
chose difficile car ces réfugiés sont
isolés dans un village de montagne
actuellement ne sont prêtés que les
personnes qui sont hébergés dans les
camps qui a été classé priorité numéro
un
donc nous avons réussi malgré tout à
convaincre le consul de traiter leur cas
zarif à elle reprend courage chaque jour
lorsqu'elle parle à son frère au
téléphone et maintenant les bombes
interviewé tout va très bien tout va
très bien
enfin fethi ousmane sy sait désormais
qu'en france sa famille fait tout pour
le faire venir il peut prendre son mal
en patience
la loi nous interdit de sortir du
village pour faire nos démarches
alors nous devons attendre que la croix
rouge viennent jusqu'à nous quelque
chose pour l'instant elle n'est pas
venue alors à foug jusqu'au chauveau là
bas de l'autre côté de la frontière
la maison de la famille osmani
ressembler à celle ci mais elle a brûlé
leur histoire est la même que celle de
tous les réfugiés une longue marche
jusqu'à la frontière macédonienne pour
fethi son épouse son neveu et sa mère
âgée de 92 ans ak mienne ils ont d'abord
été logés dans un gymnase puis chez une
famille d'agriculteurs ma pièce n'est
pas grande mais il s'en contente
quant à leur affaire elle ne les
embarrasse plus guère
quelques médicaments qui a besoin mais
c'est tout malgré cela fethi s'estime
chanceux ici comme dans tous les
villages albanais de macédoine
tous les habitants sans exception ont
accueilli une famille pour nous peu
importe que ces gens soit albanais du
kosovo
albanais de macédoine français aux
anglais ils n'ont plus de toit
alors nous les accueillons on est bien
mieux que dans un camps disent les 7000
réfugiés de khan jan
mais combien d'autant leurs hôtes déjà
très pauvre pourront-ils les accueillir
pour faîtier sa famille de nouvelles
sont bonnes ils pourront se rendre en
france dans les deux semaines à venir
l'auteur de régler les formalités
administratives pour les autres il
faudra attendre encore dans chaque
maison
dans chaque famille ici à cayenne par
exemple la population a doublé en moins
d'un mois en albanie les troupes
françaises basées jusqu'à présent sur
l'aéroport de tirana ont commencé depuis
ce matin leur redéploiement vers le sud
du pays dans le cadre de l'opération
humanitaire de l'otan baptisée abri a
lié ces soldats français ont pour
mission de porter assistance mais aussi
d'améliorer les axes routiers
sur place nos envoyés spéciaux au brier
de l'air catherine voix
c'est en milieu d'après midi que les
premières troupes françaises sont
arrivées dans la région d'el bassano sud
de tirana
après neuf heures de route 15 minutes
suffisent en hélicoptère les 80 hommes
du 1er régiment de hussards
parachutistes atteignent enfin ce qui
sera pour les mois qui viennent leur
terrain d'activités sur place les
attentes des officiers d'albanais
apparemment un peu dépassée et qu'il
faut savoir ménager première étape des
mines et nettoyer cette ancienne caserne
albanaise qui doit devenir l'état major
des forces alliées dans le sud la france
placé à sa tête il commandera outre ses
troupes
des soldats danois greg et émirati une
fois la zone assainies commencera alors
la vraie mission humanitaire de notre
temps la mission est de porter
assistance aux réfugiés et d'entretenir
le réseau routier l'armée américaine
renforce sans cesse son dispositif on
parle toujours de france yves terrestre
vous vous êtes ici pour faire de
l'humanitaire
vous n'avez pas parfois l'impression
d'un décalage nous sommes là pour faire
du magny terre et
nous contenterons de notre mission qui
nous est assignée pour le moment d'ici à
la fin du mois des renforts du génie et
des transmissions arriveront-elles
bassanne au total 800 français seront
alors déployés dans le sud de l'albanie
pour y installer près de cinquante mille
réfugiés kosovars
alors que la guerre du kosovo entre dans
son deuxième mois l'opération abri
alliés commencent à prendre forme sur le
terrain
les français seront donc placés au sud
les américains à l'égard de la position
stratégique de tirana et les italiens
très impliqué dans cette crise auront en
charge des zones frontalières du nord
est aux portes de chez eux les côtes de
l'adriatique
et puis le ministre albanais des
affaires étrangères a indiqué tout à
l'heure à washington que son pays
accepterait d'être une tête de pont pour
les forces de l'otan en cas
d'intervention terrestre au kosovo comme
chaque jour les nouveaux chiffres
communiqués par le hcr ou aux six cent
mille réfugiés s'ajoutent ceux milliers
de personnes ayant fui le kosovo ces
dernières 24 heures alors que des
centaines d'autres se trouverait dans
les montagnes en macédoine dans un état
d'extrême épuisement olivier galzi ils
sont les fantômes des montagnes
les serbes les pousse à partir les
macédoniens les empêchent de rentrer
alors ils empruntent les voies les plus
improbables
malgré leur âge malgré le froid ils
veulent fuir le kosovo ils veulent
entrer en macédoine
selon les organisations humanitaires il
serait ainsi entre quinze et vingt mille
à errer dans ces montagnes de la
frontière
ceux là ont été retrouvés dans une
mosquée affamés ils sont partis il ya
huit jours mais ne sont jamais arrivés
en route ils ont perdu cet enfant et un
vieillard
et puis il ya aussi les trains de
l'exode des charters entiers organisée
par les serbes à pristina et qui ont
déversé aujourd'hui encore des milliers
de kosovars au poste-frontière de
blatche et en macédoine côté albanais la
situation n'est guère plus enviable dans
ces camps situés à la frontière
le hcr est obligé de déplacer les
réfugiés un peu plus au sud
un peu plus loin des tirs de
l'artillerie serbes car les accrochages
sont désormais quotidiens plus au sud
jusqu'à la mer jusqu'à vlora la ville a
déjà absorbé 7000 réfugiés
et puis il ya ceux à qui il reste encore
de l'argent et qui tentent leur chance
sur des embarcations de fortune vers
l'italie
400 d'entre eux ont atteint aujourd'hui
les rivages d'otrante la police les a
retrouvés trempé abandonné sur une plage
isolée tarif du passage 3500 francs par
personne avec espère-t-il à la clé la
fin du calvaire
mais ce soir c'est un autre camp qui les
attend un camp pour immigrés clandestins
à paris la solidarité s'organise à
destination cette fois ci des serbes
victimes des bombardements
un camion transportant plusieurs tonnes
de nourriture et de médicaments devrait
quitter la france la semaine prochaine
la communauté serbe qui compte en france
quelque 80000 personnes mobilise ses
ressortissants pour qu'ils viennent en
aide à leurs compatriotes restés en
yougoslavie
patrick fandio jean-paul chaussettes la
scène se répète plusieurs dizaines de
fois par jour
un défilé de cartons et de sacs qui
s'achève dans ce garage désaffecté
le local a été prêté à la communauté
yougoslave par un ami c'est devenu le
principal centre de collecte des
d'humanitaires pour les serbes
on y trouve tout ce qui commence à
manquer à belgrade du lait des conserves
du sucre des tétines de biberon quelques
cachets d'aspirine la diaspora est plus
que jamais solidaire plus que jamais
disponibles tous sont bénévoles et tous
trice lots de vêtements usagés la gorge
serrée comme vous voyez on n'est pas
très nombreux
en fait le changement de side aider les
gens qui sont sous les bombardements
aujourd'hui que on pense pas justement
10 ou 15 millions de serbes du centre
indépendant
elle est catastrophique cette situation
sanitaire ya des gamins en pyjama qui
court dans les rues
y'a rien j'ai eu ma tante ce matin au
téléphone effectivement elle me demande
elle me demande comment saura demain
puisque lll chez elle c'est le chaos
elle est sous les bombes continuellement
ils sont révoltés par le sort de leurs
compatriotes serbes
et il s'étonne que les français ne s'en
émeuvent pas davantage pour eux mais
réfugiés albanais du kosovo n'ont pas le
monopole de la souffrance
il ne devrait pas non plus être les
seuls à bénéficier de la générosité des
associations caritatives
on n'arrive pas à avoir et bénévoles
finalement du côté des français c'est
décevant parce que ces bombes
si tout le monde fait également ses 20
tonnes de nourriture ces deux tonnes de
médicaments prendront le chemin de
belgrade en début de semaine prochaine
ce sera la troisième opération de ce
type et certainement pas la dernière
ce nouveau sondage à paraître demain
dans le journal du dimanche selon le
baromètre ifop la popularité de jacques
chirac et de lionel jospin marque une
forte hausse pour ce mois d'avril 63%
d'opinions favorables pour le président
de la république soit + 7 points par
rapport au mois de mars
lionel j'espère gagne lui onze points à
60% la crise du kosovo et l'intervention
de l'otan doivent donc la cote de
popularité aussi bien de jacques chirac
qui atteint là son plus haut niveau
depuis son arrivée à l'elysée bonds
spectaculaires pour lionel jospin qui
reste toutefois à trois points de son
niveau record en août dernier je reviens
maintenant à cette information qui nous
est parvenu un peu avant le début de ce
journal une explosion dans l'est de
londres qui aurait pu être causée par
une voiture piégée
nous retrouvons tout de suite en direct
notre correspondant etienne leenhardt
apparemment donc il s'agit d'un attentat
y at il des blessés mon sort béatrice
effectivement ce que nous savons pour
l'instant c'est qu'une explosion s'est
produite il y à peine un peu plus d'une
heure dans un quartier de l'est de lons
résident notamment une forte communauté
originaire du bangladesh il y aurait
effectivement plusieurs blessés il
semble que l'engin explosif serait du
même type que celui de la semaine
dernière dans le quartier de brixton qui
est un quartier à forte communauté noire
il y avait eu vous vous en souvenez 49
blessés quatre mouvements d'extrême
droite avait revendiqué cet attentat et
au delà de cette revendication la police
britannique privilégier l'hypothèse d'un
acte à caractère raciste alors
évidemment la question que l'on se pose
c'est de savoir si les deux attentats
sont liés on a tendance à opérer un
rapprochement à une semaine d'intervalle
les deux explosions se sont produites
pratiquement à la même heure dans deux
quartiers à forte densité de population
on n'en sait pas beaucoup plus pour
l'instant il y a des blessés au moins
trois personnes auraient été
hospitalisées et de forts dégâts
matériels merci etienne leenhardt
l'actualité politique avec la réunion
des cadres du rpr aujourd'hui à paris la
ferveur de nicolas sarkozy qui sur tous
les temps et sans ménager sa peine
prêche le rassemblement un message de
confiance derrière jacques chirac
destiné à faire oublier la crise que
traverse le parti gaulliste karl comment
prendre ça y est ils essaieraient
copieusement sifflé il ya seulement deux
ans nicolas sarkozy savoure aujourd'hui
les revirements l'histoire ovationnée
par la salle
le nouveau chef de campagne et l'ex
pourtant d'un rpr bien mal ample la
démission de philippe séguin suivi de la
fin de non-recevoir de l'udf à moins de
deux mois des élections européennes le
rpr doit tout reprendre à zéro
vivant ça nous sommes déterminés et que
nous allons entendre
rires les plus belles pages de
l'histoire
bunny
je n'ai pas mis color c'est tout ce
qu'ils font applaudir
parce que tous nous sommes comptables de
l'unité de la famille bollée un discours
combatif repris par toutes les
sensibilités du rpr si la direction du
parti a changé la stratégie de campagne
n reste la même l'adversaire privilégié
et bien la liste socialiste et tous ont
réaffirmé aujourd'hui leur volonté d'en
découdre et maintenant mes chers
compagnons il faut foncer sans faire une
minute sans aucun état d'âme sans
arrière pensée nous le devons à jacques
chirac
il ya un quart de l'actualité du
gaullisme et qui nous demande notre
soutien
jacques chirac qui dans un message lu à
la tribune par nicolas sarkozy a
réaffirmé sa confiance et sa fidélité
mouvement gaulliste comme toujours en
cas de crise le rpr vient de s'offrir
long de ces grandes démonstrations
d'unité qu'il affectionne tout
particulièrement
un moment choisi par jacques chirac pour
envoyer un message de soutien au
mouvement gaulliste
ce signe que philippe séguin avait
longtemps attendu mais en vain la grève
du personnel au sol d'air france à nice
grève qui a été reconduite une nouvelle
fois pour 24 heures un mouvement qui
perturbe partiellement le trafic aérien
les vétérans 1 diane richards dans le
hall des arrivées
les passagers ont décidé de se servir
deux heures pour certains attendre
devant le tapis roulant
c'est décidément trop ça mon incapacité
totale gérée et le personnel les gens
qui réclament et les passagers
contrairement aux apparences ce ne sont
pas les grévistes réunis en assemblée
tout l'après midi qui sont à l'origine
de ces incidents
c'est plutôt le service de bagages de
remplacement qui donne des signes de
faiblesse
on a su qu'il y avait un container
bagage complet qui manquait la direction
qui fait le travail à notre place
la laisser dans l'école dans la dans les
avions dans les soutes d'avion et en
aucun cas à cause de grévistes
côté négociations le dialogue a repris
un peu cet après midi mais après vingt
minutes d'entretien les grévistes n'ont
rien obtenu de satisfaisant pour
l'instant la direction ressources en
projet de sous-traitance
ce qui fait que l'intersyndicale a dû
quitté la salle rapidement
il faut savoir que la direction ne sait
pas trop comment sortir de la sphère le
personnel au sol d'air france ne veut
absolument pas lâcher le service bagages
à la sous-traitance
la direction tient à ce projet et attend
beaucoup des futures négociations
72 % du trafic a été assuré avec des
retards souvent mais la contestation
elle ne faiblit pas les grévistes se
retrouveront demain matin pour discuter
des négociations de la nuit
l'actualité sociale encore avec
l'annoncé faite hier de la suppression
d'un peu plus d'un millier d'emplois
chez ibm à corbeil essonnes légende de
l'informatique américain a expliqué
cette décision par sa volonté de
restructuration en association avec
l'allemand siemens dominique bar couche
virgilia de conciliabules dans les
couloirs c'est travailleront bleus
viennent d'apprendre que près d'un sur
deux est ton trou leur usine à
corbeil-essonnes et pourtant l'une est
des plus modernes d'europe
mais ibm france vient d'annoncer récit
près de 1200 suppressions d'emplois dont
340 licenciement on a demandé aux gens
tirent les sacrifices d'avoir moins 1,7
pour cent sur leur salaire les gens ont
fait l'effort pour que ça aille mieux
ensuite on leur dit ben non vous avez
fait l'effort tout ibm france confondus
et vous corbeil-essonnes où récupérer
rien de tous en raison de la crise
la surproduction du marché mondial de la
mémoire d'ordinateur une cinquantaine
d'usinés fermées dans le monde ces douze
derniers mois
les énormes investissements dits bm à
corbeil 5 milliards de fonds il y à
peine deux ans n'ont rien empêché voyez
qu'il ya six ans ont stocké la même
quantité d'informations aujourd'hui
contenues dans cette puce il nous
fallait cette surface de silicium 16
puces équivalente et malgré tout on
assiste en parallèle depuis plusieurs
années en particulier depuis trois ans à
une dégringolade vertigineuse des prix
la société a donc décidé de se
réorienter vers la production de
mémoires d'ordinateurs plus sophistiqués
dans le cadre d'une alliance ponctuelle
avec l'allemand siemens mais
l'amputation est d'autant plus
douloureuse ici qu ibm vient d'annoncer
des bénéfices exceptionnels au niveau du
groupe
la communauté arménienne manifestaient
aujourd'hui pour obtenir enfin la
reconnaissance du génocide de 1915
plusieurs milliers de personnes à paris
de l'assemblée nationale au sénat le
sénat qui n'a pas finalement inscrit à
l'ordre du jour la proposition de loi
qui avait été adoptée à l'unanimité il
ya près d'un an benoît thevenet
sébastien legay
comme chaque 24 avril ils se sont
retrouvés en souvenir du génocide de
mais aujourd'hui à paris le cortège de
la communauté arménienne n'a pas conduit
les manifestants devant l'ambassade de
turquie mais devant le sénat car si
l'assemblée nationale a voté une loi
reconnaissant le génocide arménien le
sénat n'a encore rien entrepris par
crainte des réactions de la turquie ni
le gouvernement ni la majorité
sénatoriale l'ont inscrit à l'ordre du
jour l'examen de ce texte par les
sénateurs en n'acceptant pas le devoir
de mémoire en encourageant également la
turquie dans son attitude négationnistes
mais pas seulement l'égard des arméniens
mais avait également à l'égard des
chypriotes à l'égard du fait kurde l
égard de sa propre démocratie
je crois qu'il ya un encouragement fie à
mon avis une erreur peut l'emporter tout
art il y à 84 ans à l'aube du 24 avril
1915 commence deux ans de massacres et
de déportations l'empiré ottoman décide
de se débarrasser des arméniens les
hommes en âge de combattre sont
systématiquement tué à coups de sabre ou
de fusil les femmes et les enfants sont
poussées sur les routes de l'exil mais
beaucoup mourront en chemin assassiné
violet ou exténué les massacres ont fait
plus d'un million deux cent mille morts
selon les arméniens
plus de la moitié de la population
lorsqu'un plan d'extermination lorsque
tout un peu près a été exterminée et
déporté il peut y avoir un autre mot il
ne peut y avoir un autre mot que vaut
mon génocide bac
cette journée du souvenir est célébrée
partout dans le monde par la diaspora
arménienne et notamment à erevan la
capitale de l'arménie où toute la
population se rend au mémorial et puis à
lyon maintenant une marche symbole qui a
démarré aujourd'hui emmenant quelques
centaines de personnes pour cette
première étape
une marche qui devrait s'achever le 12
mai prochain soit 550 kilomètres
parcourus par ses membres de la
communauté arménienne il ya décidé à
obtenir la reconnaissance du génocide
que je vous le rappelle à ses plus d'un
million de morts du tennis au tournoi de
monte carlo le ch il n'ya marcello ríos
13e joueur mondial a éliminé le français
jérôme golmard cet après midi 6 4 3 6 6
2 le nouveau numéro un français avait
sorti en rappel elle éveille le tenant
du titre ystari l'espagnol carlos moya
et deuxième mondial lieu ça comptera
dimanche le brésilien pointe m
la célèbre chorégraphe pina bausch
fidèles à paris présente au théâtre de
la ville son nouveau spectacle inspiré
de son voyage à lisbonne
comme à chaque fois une oeuvre créatrice
original où l'on retrouve la chaleur et
la sensualité de l'atmosphère portugaise
michelle celui-ci france d'ailleurs
la scène transformée en plage soleil
joie de vivre séduction c'est lisbonne
recréé par la chorégraphe pina bas
sa compagnie en résidence au portugal
s'est imprégné de sa chaleur
elle nous en restic toute la sensualité
et le goût de la fête
pina bausch sous le charme de son propre
spectacle
je ne savais pas qu'une chose aussi fort
et est enfermé en moi j'en suis surprise
moi aussi j'ai ressenti fortement avec
ce spectacle une énergie nouvelle et
c'est sorti comme ça
la rencontre des cultures c'est ce qui
me passionne
pina bausch lc mêler les gestes les
techniques et les idées pour donner
naissance à une oeuvre originale
inspirée de la vie et qui ne la copie
jamais
et comme toujours chez pina bausch la
communion avec la nature
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres le temps
se prononce pour la mise en place d'un
blocus naval dans l'adriatique pour
empêcher l'approvisionnement en pétrole
de la yougoslavie
la france émet des réserves quant à
l'application de ce blocus
moscou déclare ne pas vouloir respecter
cet embargo
les cadres du rpr réunis à paris à
l'unisson autour de nicolas sarkozy qui
prêche pour le rassemblement et l'unité
derrière jacques chirac dans un instant
la météo lors hormis ce coup puis tapis
rouge à tapis rouge exceptionnel michel
drucker reçoit ce soir francis cabrel et
patricia kaas le dernier journal
laurence ostolaza de master dont il
caffè catherine ceylac reçoit le
chanteur kent et puis enzo enzo midi
polémique michèle cotta aura pour invité
robert hue je vous retrouve demain dès
13 heures je vous remercie de votre
attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2